what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I have two
special guests on the channel say hi
Gabby hi say hi Michael so today we are
red pilling my friend Gabby even further
so Gabby tell us hi I'm
outside from the beginning phases
so um you've been read a lot in the last
year I've changed a lot so describe your
mindset a year ago a year ago I
everything Pearl said instantly made me
want to throw up cry scream and there
was a period of time where I told her I
didn't want to be friends with her
because of red pill things but then they
always come back one day it started to
make sense
what made sense it's just things that I
think that a lot of red pill stuff and I
mean initially right like I'm a girl I
don't I have to think about a lot of
these things and so I'd hear like things
that you'd say or whatever and I'd be
like no no we hate we hate toxic yeah
like you know I just in general and then
I just started to realize like wow okay
it's true that you know women we ask for
a lot from men like traditional things
yeah but we don't have traditional
things to give them because we're modern
women
and I never had thought about that and
it's like I don't know so now it's kind
of it's kind of an unfair deal for men
isn't it I mean in some ways yeah yeah
it is because you know we what do we
want from like or what do a lot of women
want from a guy a guy that's gonna pay
the bills and take care of you and
protect you but like we women don't do
don't take care of our the men and
you're interesting because you're kind
of like a modern woman with a bit of
Traditional Values I think it comes I'm
Italian if you guys didn't know
um and I was raised very like with
Traditional Values coming from like the
cultural background and so I think
that's kind of just and you know what's
funny I think women we would be happier
if we could act more traditional in
relationships like do I mean like I
think when you actually cook and clean
for a guy and like oh I love it yeah it
like feeds my soul in a way because it's
like I but I also think I just kind of
have that motherly nurturing kind of in
me just because I was raised that way
like brought up that way and so it makes
me happy to take care of people or like
especially a guy AI that I like care
about or love like taking care of him
like it it fills my cup so what was like
the first thing that you changed your
mind on ooh that you were like at first
and you heard it you were trick I'll
tell you I'll tell you my first from Red
Pill stuff okay you tell me yours so my
my first was cheating so when I first
heard Kevin Samuel say high value men
can cheat and should cheat I was
triggered I'm still triggered me no wait
wait okay but listen listen and his
whole point was if you go for a guy in
the top like five percent of all men so
he he's handsome tall successful famous
rich like everything that women want
yeah why would you expect him to be
faithful well that I mean like they're
never never like an NBA player they're
never faithful you know what's funny I
remember when I was like when I first
started dating my step Grandma we were
watching NBA game and she was like Gabby
I feel like these are the type of guys
you're gonna date one day you need to
stay away from them it's just like they
will never be faithful to you and she
was like you don't want to be Khloe
Kardashian I was like Grandma's a red
pill she is you'd have her on the show
and and that's what that's what he was
saying was those men in a way they
earned the right to cheat because women
want those guys we they almost prefer
those guys that can cheat and I'm not
gonna say and so it's like
it's like that how can we be mad that
you get cheated on it I mean that's fair
like you know what you're getting into
yeah when you're dating someone of of
high value High status like you you know
what you're getting into and it's the
same thing with like even the best even
at a lower level let's take the
basketball players out out in in Europe
they're all Sheen too I mean even
cheating left right and Center and they
have kids and baby mamas that they flew
out from America living with them in
Europe and they still cheat
they still cheat this one sounds a bit
broken
it sounds like he's what I mean you
should start crying
but it's like so that that's what he was
saying he wasn't saying like all men
should cheat but he's saying high value
men have earned the right to cheat
because the women will put up with it
they will look together oh that's true
well I think it's interesting too like
when you've talked about polygamy and
like how women are a lot more open to it
and it's just it's so interesting to me
because I mean I know I could never do
it but I know that there's a lot of
women that really would like to have
everything that you want from a guy or
even just the financial aspect of him
like taking care of you they will share
yeah not me though
so what about you like what was the so
that was the first thing that I was
triggered by and then I I sort of
understood and I came around understood
what he was saying what was the first
thing that I said that triggered you
I don't know
I just remember like when you first
started the show and I mean we've had we
had some conversations like when we were
in Paris and you kind of you were like
laying it on me that you were like
conservative you're like testing the
water and I was like oh yeah like you
know because I mean that obviously that
never bothered me I I just because like
My Views are different and I've never
seen that as to me issue I think it was
no I think it was when you um said like
women love to be victims because that's
what real that one really set me off but
I get where you're coming from now yeah
it's not that women like love to be
victims it's they victimize themselves
and they sometimes I'm not saying all
women but some women will use it as a
tool like like to get what they want
yeah and a lot of times they just don't
take accountability for them the part
they had to play yeah so like I would
agree an example is that most domestic
abuse is multi-sided means they're both
hitting each other yeah and like a lot
of girls will forget to add in the part
where they were they a lot of times hit
him first and then it's like what did
you expect well I I I I hear you I feel
like if you are a larger man and like
there's a I'm not saying that it's right
and that women should not hit men nobody
everyone just hold hands no one hit each
other no weapons like you know Kumbaya
but if you're a larger man and a smaller
woman is hitting you and she hits you
and then you rock her I can't really get
with that okay so what if what if
Michael went up to Dwayne The Rock
Johnson and hit him and Dwayne The Rock
Johnson knocked him the out would
you feel would you feel bad for Michael
hell no
[Applause]
men and women will both do that Ralph
that's what would happen bro do you get
what I'm saying and usually more in in
most scenarios a woman is always going
to be smaller than the guy so like
really intriguing I said in most in most
scenarios walk stronger at least at
least at least stronger at least
stronger so because a lot of times you
could get a woman who is maybe tall or
whatever or large but a skinnier smaller
guy will still be stronger than her do
you get what I'm saying so that don't
mean nothing so always remember that
guys nobody put hands on anybody how
about that
but like my whole point is then the girl
will say I was abused that was this that
was that but it's like you started you
started
and like women like to be victims and
they like to tell these SOB stories
because it gives them the attention they
want instead of and they don't take
accountability I will say that they're I
agree that that does happen yeah but I
do think in situations when it comes to
abuse and stuff like that I mean it
definitely is not always reported when a
woman is beating a man or like putting
hands on a man but I do think that
sometimes men like in a relationship
women get pushed to a point and then
maybe they'll do something or they've
been I don't know did you hear what I'm
saying no no because I just feel like
then you should leave like some people
can't sometimes financially you can't
leave it's and then also I mean but to
me that's that's kind of an excuse like
if we reverse the roles right let's say
we reverse it and it's a man with a
woman and maybe financially like they're
splitting the bills 50 50. like I'm not
gonna feel I don't want to say I will
feel bad but like you you have to take
an accountability for the situation you
put yourself in yeah 100 yeah and so if
she's cheating on him and then he one
day beats her ass because like he he she
pushed him to that point nobody would
really get like give him the benefit of
the job no absolutely not but it's
interesting because you don't realize
how much we have these double standards
where like women can say they abuse the
guy because they're pushed to a certain
point but men like what what if Michael
beat up a girl because she was cheating
and doing wild right that's how how
exercise yeah I'm getting put on the
ground for that right yeah on the ground
you your life would never be the same
never but but you know it's okay she's
still getting red pilled I'm on my way
guys
I'm I'm listening and I'm taking it in
and I'm actually agreeing so we're gonna
um listen to Why
um what is the cat what was it labeled
blessing we are educated and make money
why do we need men oh okay that's the
title of the video so we're gonna react
to it so let's play it
moving slowly through the yard
through my mind my disagreement is just
basically about the fact that black
women shouldn't have to feel obligated
to smile to black men we're holding a
lot of trauma we're holding a lot of
problems mental health issues
I'm gonna tell you I'm gonna say this
one more time I need you to pay
attention I need all black but the world
does not owe you understand if you have
all this trauma professional because the
rest of us do not have to suffer you
okay what do you guys think of that uh I
just feel like I'm just sick and tired
of hearing about this trauma Fair like
you're not the only one everyone's got
trauma in my eye if you're a man woman
black white don't matter brother
everyone's got their own trauma so bro
you're not you're not special that's
just the way I see it and I I really
just don't I just ignore when people
come out with that kind of talk I just
ignore it at the end of the day like
just a lot of times it's like when women
go through stuff is like the world has
to stop like and it's just like guys
when we go through stuff is we get told
to man up so why don't you woman up bro
yeah that's just my that's why I take on
it and that's it so I don't know if you
agree or what do you think um personally
I just feel like she's talking about her
experience as a black woman I can't
really I don't have an opinion because
that's not my experience I I can't what
about what if we took the race out of it
and it was just like what if what if she
was a white woman and she said like we
have trauma and like the same argument
but let's just say she was white I mean
I think what Michael said is like
everyone has trauma okay yeah but I mean
I I just can't speak on her experience
because the way that I've had to live in
the world or whatever is completely
different than a black woman's
experience so well I just think that
um I just don't like like have making
other people pay for the sins of your
past you know and it's like if you have
an ex-boyfriend or an ex that did
something to you like why do the men of
your future have to pay for that I don't
know okay let's let's continue
you know the Tumbleweed
producer we need that animation tumble
weeds
need that black women and black people
do you not in the black community to get
health responsibility is it but it's not
available
[Music]
what he's saying is absolutely true as
obviously as a member of the black
community that is facts bro like most of
the time men or women because I'm not
going to say just particularly black
women but I just think black people in
general don't really seek counseling and
stuff like that unless we're forced to
do it the only time I ever went into any
kind of counseling is because I was
forced to do it by my school you get
what I'm saying because I had certain
things happen but apart from that I've
never thought in my head let me go to
speak to a counselor you know like my
background my parent my mom or whatever
she would never dream to go and see she
would see that as like some weird thing
to go and do and I think really and
truly in my community it's not really
the the kind of thing to do to go and
you know go and talk about all your
problems to other people you're kind of
just in you just kind of get on with it
and as well and you see it you see it
manifested in a lot of ways like you
know you see a lot of people in my
community
um doing dysfunctional things committing
crime you know being extra promiscuous
etc etc because of like you know trauma
that they have experienced and not
really
um solved it or not really talked to
someone who's a professional so I agree
with him that yeah but at the same time
as I said everybody's experience trauma
so you know that's what that's what I've
got to say what do you think is the
difference between how do you tell the
difference between a good therapist and
a bad therapist because I have such
mixed views on therapy because on one
hand like I do see the value in it but
at the other hand I I I feel like some
therapists come in and make worse
like they almost like confuse the people
like I don't know yeah I hear you I I
went through I'm on my seventh therapist
but I've had I've been with her since I
was 16. so but I had to go through a lot
of different like stat like styles that
didn't work for me until I found the
style of therapy that did work for me so
I also think it's just kind of like some
I think with some patients like a more
aggressive style of therapy works where
as for me what what worked with me is
her letting me come to my own
conclusions like let it literally her
knowing these things and then like years
later I finally come to this conclusion
she's like yeah I've known this since
like the first month
wow you couldn't tell me this
there's ever too long to be going to
therapy because to me it's like aren't
you not doing your job if like you're
still in therapy years later I you know
I look at it completely different way I
think that therapy is a great tool to
get an unbiased opinion and I think it's
a beautiful thing to always be working
on yourself and sometimes you just need
someone who doesn't know you personally
just to listen and and give advice that
from someone that's highly educated and
just can give you a different
perspective and you can't there are
people in your life that can give you
that but I think that having a
professional give you that can be
extremely beneficial it's not for
everybody I will say that no I don't I
don't have like an issue with there I
kind of do I don't know I have such a
mixed opinions on it because I do think
there's people that have like gone
through trauma but at the same time I
feel like some therapists will convince
people that they've gone through trauma
and like make them victims I hear you
and it's like later like they'll come
out like worse and I feel like therapy
should almost have like an end date like
if you if because I'm like if you're
going for years it doesn't seem like
you've progressed if you're still in it
well I think that you know it's like
it's an uphill battle some you're gonna
go through periods of life where I think
that it'll be better and then other
times where I don't think that it's ever
like uh I like am done in my opinion I
feel like you can always be working on
yourself and therapy doesn't always have
to be just like unloading trauma it can
be just learning like more about
yourself or just getting things off your
chest and getting I mean it's an
expensive opinion but it's a good
opinion to have I think what do you mean
like working on yourself can I have an
example like I've never done like
long-term therapy I've just done yeah a
little bit but not I mean I can't speak
for other people I know me personally
going to therapy it it's not always like
every session it's this deep like
intense talking about all the trauma and
abuse in my past it's like sometimes I'm
just like yeah you know this week I
really like just was feeling sad or you
know and then sometimes like yeah this
week was really good and it's kind of
just like talking with a friend but then
eventually at some point it'll be like
it's like I figure something out about
myself and learn something out about
myself that I don't think it would have
taken me a lot longer in Life or I don't
know it's it's like I just for me gives
me a different perspective because I
just think and this is this is
uneducated like I've never spent a ton
of time in therapy but like if I have
something that makes me sad if I spend a
ton of time talking about it like I'm
gonna get sadder but it's kind of like
if you listen to like sad music all the
time you're gonna feel sad but if you
listen to Happy music you'll be like I'm
happy you know but I think you know just
because you if you're feeling an emotion
and you kind of being like Oh well if I
just think about it then I'll get more
sad that's you pushing the emotion away
that doesn't mean it goes away it's
still there but it kind of does for me
honestly like I swear to God if I'm sad
I'm trying to be like you Pearl there's
like research on this if you like I've
been in situations where I'm like sad
but if you pretend to be happy long
enough like your butt your it like
tricks your brain like to think make it
yeah like they think you're ha it thinks
you're happy where I found like if I
just sit and like complain about my
problems like I I personally have never
found that effective unless it's like
maybe you know some people have like
Secrets or like stuff they've never
talked about for years and need to tell
someone but it's like how long do you
need to do that for to the point where
it almost like it seems like it would
make it worse I think I think that yeah
they will need you will need a lot a
period of time where you kind of kind of
express yourself and you know whatever
it is that's getting you down to make
you feel upset but like what's more
important is the solution so that you
can reach your end goal like because
it's I do agree it's kind of like you're
going round and round in circle when
you're not getting any better you're
just going from from point A to B and
then back to a again like do you get
what I'm saying so yeah you may need
that time to be like you know this
happened and like kind of little you're
feeling ends out but there has to be a
solution like so you can progress and
move forward that's what and I've
noticed a lot of therapists are like
older single women and I'm kind of like
if you can't maintain a relationship why
would I take advice from you
I'm just this is just something I've
noticed
um
but again I haven't spent a ton of time
in therapy but then like and then I'm
like yeah like why would I take advice
from you if you can't maintain
relationships you know one thing I'll
say about that I feel like you've kind
of got more of a guy's brain when it
comes to these kind of things like
you're more logic based like okay
um have a problem well in this in this
area
I feel like in this instance you're
seeing it from my point of view that
like okay there's a problem what's the
solution I don't want to just carry on
moaning about it was whereas I feel like
you know not all not at all but I think
a lot of women will kind of prefer to
just kind of complain you know what I'm
saying and just talk and talk I want to
talk about it it doesn't I don't care
about the solution I just want to talk
about it kind of thing and I've heard
many women like even my own mum she's
like that she would just want to talk
about the problem over and over and
bring it up again like you know I mean
instead of okay let's fix this so I
think in that in that respect I think
you you've got more of like a kind of um
logical mind as yeah let's get this over
and it's not it's not like like I think
that people that have experienced
extreme trauma oh my gosh do you know
what's crazy
um there is a girl that came from
oh my god um North Korea and she she has
oh I've seen yeah and she had she had
the most extreme like like anything bad
that could ever happen to someone this
girl went through and then she came to
the U.S and she heard about therapy and
she was so confused she was like wait
you're going to therapy you need to talk
to someone about your problems why would
you do that and she's like my roommate
was in therapy about her ex-boyfriend
and I'm out here like I escaped North
Korea
it does think he puts everything in
perspective for sure yeah because a lot
of times the things we're complaining
about especially in the First World
countries like bro it's really not that
deep like obviously some some things are
that deep but a lot of times the things
we'll complain about are very trivial
you know what I'm saying that's true but
I also think that when you like what you
go through personally and your path and
your story compared to someone else it's
gonna seem small but to you it's your
that's your life you know what I'm
saying so it I feel like that if you
just are always like well someone else
has it worse that's not you
acknowledging that you do go through
these certain things or that you do have
those type of emotions and I always
think that's helpful I mean I I feel
like you can acknowledge I don't know
have you ever been to like have you ever
found out that someone close to you or
someone that you know or a friend of a
friend got like cancer or something or
something serious like that and you just
kind of wake up the next day and you're
like you know what my problems aren't
that bad yeah and I I I think it's like
helpful to be grateful for like the
problems you don't have
um I don't know definitely I I no I
agree 100
um but let's let's continue the video
push to us since no no we are little oh
no man no I asked who let's see asked
who they we're not going to play I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna play The Lily did he
go to a clinician the church most often
all right and these are educated
companies most of these and they've
heard about their they make the choice
not no different than I'ma switch it up
no different than women understanding
here that being 200 pounds and five foot
tall is unhealthy but yet 80 of our
women are overweight and 80 of that is
obese they know the truth
the narrative pushed to us most often is
that a guy wants a woman with a big ass
he wants you know a thick lady
accountability all the accountability is
Kryptonite to Modern women man you you
say the traumas if I accept them then
you gotta do something because what
about the traumas that the black man has
to deal with but we still have to get
out here and be functioning people in
society contributing there you go you
don't get to walk around and say you
don't get to walk around and say have a
special victim status I'm not saying we
should have a special victim status but
our circumstance is different we are
women
we're 24 years old is your circum is
your circumstance harder or easier than
your grandmother and your great grandma
exponentially easier we have access to
information we didn't exponentially
easier but you're handling it work your
grandmother your great-grandmother
actually could work with a black man
with more trauma because they understood
that the black woman and the black man
are on the same side now that we are all
free and independent and to we could do
whatever we want to why would we see you
know be one with the black man
thank you thank you thank you spice it
put it on Worldstar she said it not me
now that you're independent you don't
lose me there you go there you go and
there you go and there you go there you
go black man there it is she's finally
finally got one to say
your grandmothers and your grandmothers
and your great-grandmothers had more
trauma and more stress and did it better
they have exponentially less and they're
handling it works but it's because
they're free you can do what the hell
they want they'll need to be with you so
you don't need to feel any guilt for
taking care of you for putting yourself
first and making your passion your
purpose your priority you don't need to
feel guilty because this 24 year old
woman just said it they have no they
don't feel any guilt about it that was
wild that was wild that she said that
and I think I think it goes across the
board in our current time like in a
modern era a lot of women even
irrespective of like race or the race
Dynamic I think that a lot of the
freedoms that we have these days has
kind of actually pulled us further apart
than ever before and I think we forget
that we need man like we once you get to
a certain income level we forget that we
actually depend on man and society would
not function without man and we think
like girls hit a certain financial
status and just think we don't need them
even girls that are not even on that
financial status the girls that are
broke
government assistance
you're not a boss of anything bro
stupid
what do you think just regardless I'm
not trying to focus on the race aspect
of what she was saying but more of the
rhetoric of like not needing men I know
I need men
I don't know about her I need men
because I can't even get my Wi-Fi to
work
I need someone to fix things for me
um yeah I don't know that was crazy that
she said that out loud that oh now that
I'm independent why would I like bruh
that is what then stay alone and why are
you complaining why did you call this oh
if you're free to do whatever you want
then do whatever you want there you go
bro like why are you complaining you
don't make sense yeah I don't get it
it's interesting because things like
this like I I used to be so like yeah
independent woman like whatever but
those are the same women that are lonely
it's and it's true and I never saw it
before and now I see it you know what's
funny
I'll always say like the same girl that
said she's independent and don't need a
man will be making her man breakfast the
next day and I kind of used to think of
you
matching because I was like I was like
the same girls would be like I would
never submit they'll be submit making
breakfast in the morning do you want to
massage me
my brother sent me this Tick Tock and it
was like um I'll show you later and I'm
not gonna say it right so I'm just gonna
stop talking though actually so I'll
just show you later but it had to do
with that
um okay guys um let me know what you
guys think in the comments I miss Kevin
Samuels so much I literally miss his
live streams
um like the video on your way out thank
you for watching and go subscribe go
subscribe to King Rich's Channel let's
subscribe to King Rich's Channel please
guys thank you like the video on your
way out and we'll talk to you next time